hello welcome to a new video a 15-minute
game played on the ICC's a 15 minute
auto pairing I'm playing black and I've
got a Catalan opening here was g3 okay
let's see what what what I could play am
trying something different here trying
to transpose into a bogo Indian setup
let's see what happens 96 Knight f3
would actually transpose into the bogo
Indian yum ok so now I can take he takes
with the Queen now I can play 94 Queen B
form this is some already quite ok for
black I'm surprised that he's thinking
really ok Queen dear Queen d2 he avoided
so blacks idea basically wants to
exchange this dark squared bishop and
now setting up a position on the dark
squares with this pawn so that the c8
bishop is a good bishop
yeah y term young white place this I
just wanted to mention that no there's
not much else yeah here white could
could play eform yeah I'll be form h3 is
a bit yeah I don't know doesn't really
address any direct point in this
position but it's not bad all right I'll
play a five preventing the some before
idea at least for the moment so I'm here
i can actually castle yeah let's castle
so what a wide splenium he's got this a
three before plan or this one with f
form coming and like usually just down
posts the night to see five so should I
play this now or is this some exchange a
problem for me if you would take on c5
this would actually allow me to play a
98 2d6 but he could some immediately
play a form all right I don't want to
spend so much time in those 15 minute
games i tend to take so long form rather
early moves that I'm in huge time travel
Layton I'm trying to avoid that at least
for a bit if possible
yeah surprising that him that he takes
so long him and me not taking looks very
strange
ok so now I've form f 4 would be the ok
doesn't play a form yeah the question
are really 90 idea gets a 98 26 and on f
form I have two basic ideas i can let
them take ok it seems to you want the
team she wants to prepare this more
thoroughly certainly possible
so on fri must think about if i want to
take this is actually sometimes an idea
maybe not in this position but taking an
f5 some bet here because it can take a
five but now i'm not quite sure should I
play f6 or should I let him take on the
five and then adjust recapture with the
Queen then it's um yeah I cannot do
without f5 and f6 in the long run
so difficult now i'm a bit behind in
development so f'd xe5 would be an idea
if my bishop would already be on d6 d7 i
take now and he takes he just went so
much time because i have to misplace a
piece oh I think I need to take with the
Queen or not f3 I could take but now he
protected the pawn and threatening
Knight f3 so Bishop d7 young we should
be 79 f 3 Queen h5 and e5 mhm doesn't
look too great
but what should I do and the snider
three is some quite an annoying move
maybe rook e8 rookie 893 queen age five
hmm okay let's do this to prevent d Fife
at least four move I hope to prevent it
I mean it sound not out of the question
that he might try to play this anyway
but maybe I can go all night f7 to cover
if I've even more so if he plays a move
like Quincy 3 for example 2 okay on 23
and my team take on e4 okay g4 I can
just take if he kicks my queen and if we
gives me some time actually my position
isn't so bad if i have enough time let's
say Bishop d7 rookie 7 rookie aid piling
up on the e porn from structural point
of view I'm quite good but not not well
developed here
here really the sort of it's sort of
chords 45 but I don't see how it should
be possible I mean slow moves I'm really
help me
d 5 ft xe5 Queen c3 maybe but and then I
have also if form and how to believe
that this is great for white
hmm yeah really curious maybe here it
should have actually prevent a few
prepared all this a bit more the moral I
i look at this position the more like it
for me but I might be completely off as
possible because it's a bit shaky with
the development if he somehow has a good
idea to open this up I might be in
trouble but I don't see I don't see I
don't see anything
maybe a move like rook rook somewhere
rookie to Brooke Fe one rookie three
something like this rookie three modern
I might have not f5 it's technically but
it doesn't bring much rookie to back-end
I don't ever move yeah he's taking his
time here understandably sort of really
looks like it's just a question of white
something now our black will be okay and
some small move really means some that
black has nothing to worry about I don't
see em really yeah sort of big idea here
if there is something it should be
connected with the 5v5 take Sam but I
threaten you 524 immediately after
taking
okay and this shouldn't be the move to
really turn the tables here what is the
idea maybe nine yards may not so bad 92f
for could be an idea or Bishop e3 just
attacking the queen but I have Queen g3
or something no big deal so let's try to
complete our development here
play some push up f3 indeed I mean it
really looks a bit silly but I can go
yeah maybe even Queenie 5 back here okay
so night f form where should i go on
night f4 maybe just to h6 okay I'm see
me as I'm seeing an idea no my first
idea was a rookie seven but maybe you
can go nite a form to d3 and then play
five so maybe I should um I should play
b6 here protecting c5 young okay let's
play be six so we're now even Queen even
25 to to d4 it's not not ridiculous at
all normal move would be something like
Queen h6 here no ng5 doesn't make much
sense Queen age six looks a bit off side
okay maybe after a queen age sexy can i
can just prepare the c5 move okay so
let's have a look at Queen d525 93 Queen
deform it's a bit precarious and don't
have much much squares many squares much
squares a strange strange English I
guess um okay but I'm attacking c4
immediately and also a form
ok I go I go for this if I lose my queen
then bad luck
but I really don't see them an idea if
I'm to to win it okay he just am
prepared all this good move i guess so a
five maybe a five to open up the a phone
stomach we need to go to deform
okay let's pick pal a quicker here I
don't want to one don't want to be a in
a good position later and then blunder
this away I'm 93 I cannot take because
95 d7 is hanging so on 93 actually have
to move to Queenie and I mean I could go
to to h5 after all and then I'll night F
form decide on on some other square
hard to tell
but still 9325 looks like the most
active move also just attacking you form
of it now maybe a look at f/4 would be
an idea ok let's open up da phone
shouldn't be a shouldn't be too bad for
me maybe maybe I just see a completely
different idea here I was so content
with this night on d6 maybe it still I
can play Knight f7 soldered on on this
[ __ ] this 93 I can play 26 and then e 5
just just capture all this yeah this
looks like a very very safe idea not
venturing into some weird queen position
on deform actually in this mrs. Queen D
for that I was worried about a rook f4
then e 5 threatened i'm not sure but now
i can just drop back here and on e5 i
think i can just take it he could try to
to second poem ok but now 95 on 95
rookie five and then it's a total
blockade hear of this pawn and then i
can try to put pressure on this porn
with rookie a rookie 7 Bishop EA to g6
stuff like this yeah this is very nice
long also any minor piece and game would
be great
mm okay this is not doing much I wait
what we write not so quick maybe I need
to think about rook g5 but ok it's not
great at the moment you can play a five
but Rock g5 is a move to to think about
another interesting idea would be to
play h 5 h 5 h form i'm in this i'm on
this diagonal here Oh Luke g5 we must
play rook rook on the G file h5 you can
play h4 hmm
hey
so how should I improve him
rookie 7l rookie 7b should be a team I
play Bishop chief form with the idea of
entering only six which is so not too
great I shouldn't allow this maybe
I could also swept swap the seco Brooke
move Queenie five not much benefit
though
hmm hard to tell okay let's play this
first here and see what is coming up
with okay 10 it's really ignoring this
disk of this idea look here now we
cannot play it try need to play G 4 I
know h5 shouldn't this be good for me h5
we cannot really defend you form and if
you place H form then just drop to 60
ok
so if I just take all I mean just with
heavy pieces on e5 and then at the end
he takes h5 king of 7 Bishop g4 maybe
but I can play we should be eight okay
come on this is a clearly better end
game and quite quite simple to play I
hope
until he's got this some weak pawn and I
a firm have a pest porn here
yeah now Bishop f5 this really should
decide the game Bishop f5 to see two and
a bishop exchange should just win yeah
Bishop f5 the ship f3 Bishop see two
just to answer wins all these pawns
didn't really look at this move
yeah I was a bit too quick he and I
could have played just Bishop g4 and
then it's really over and stupid really
stupid
okay so if i drop this back a threaten
bishop eh it is a threat he can play
kingi form
how do I actually win this it would be
heartbreaking not to win Bishop g5 was
just just over
okay I try I try something else here
trying to play Bishop f1
I mean it's no big deal he cannot really
do anything and I have a bit of time to
to improve the position
okay this didn't do much good
and don't see you when
Bishop d7 hope is not three-time
repetition yeah
I'm not sure Bishop d7 is this three
times the only reason i played this
movie s to avoid a possible repetition
I'm not quite sure
I think it's only two times
yeah I'm Bishop f5 just to quickly
played so this was a was my idea so I
was thinking about now c6 maybe c6
just to make some progress in this
position maybe not bad if he takes
Bishop takes it's still this zombie
three go on to attack and d6 I think I
can check and then play king e 66 just
grab the pawn this should should help so
I think he needs to take the app Bishop
g4 earlier was just just so much quicker
okay so check first young to get his
King back
if he takes with the pawn now I can go
with the King to d6 and I think just
take the pawn like Bishop f7 EIA 87 and
just grab this thing so he needs to take
with the bishop and then Bishop f5 p.m.
then Bishop f5 he takes with an Bishop
Bishop f5 threatening Bishop c2 and if
he goes we should be faunal I can
exchange and then I have King e6 the
difference with the position before when
they were pawns on c7 and d5 I couldn't
go King e6 ok so it's this winning I
hope so King you 60 can play age 6 I
take h5 King f-16 d5 King f5 King c64
takes III am just far too quick so
that's that should be really that this
should be the end Bishop c2 will windows
be three pawn
yeah I missed the Sun this in comparison
much easier when Bishop g4 otherwise it
didn't look so bad this game may be in
the opening I was in trouble it looked a
bit a bit tricky really
so question no just grabbing age 5 or is
there something better
okay let's let's check here and now i
can also go King e6 first yep he's a bit
isn't suks wrong here
b3 and h5 cannot cannot keep both but
also the time yeah coined interesting
game um what I'd try a song I want to
have a look at this position out of the
opening and CM if white had something
come something special down just to
check this quickly with the with the
computer this was the position right
where he played this move yeah the
computer wants to play rookie three
rookie three rogue everyone and give
this as about equal it's very slight
advantage to black okay then there
wasn't anything concrete I mean it
didn't see anything while looking at
this for three minutes but sometimes I
mean you're just blind but it wants to
play rookie three along the lines what I
suggested I think this was was really
better but like it's okay from a
structure point of view if he's not
getting blown away okay so I and then I
want to show quickly this this end game
because to us a bit a bit too quick
maybe
yeah amazingly the computer only gives
us a slide no no no no no it's switching
to cleared wantage okay this is somewhat
reassuring yeah and now Bishop g4 just
picks up the the edge porn yeah I was I
simply didn't didn't pay attention that
he on on Bishop f5 can play king of
three I think it might be winning anyway
but this is tricky I think the way it
happened this c6 really helped here
maybe we should be formed to prevent c6
and this is I think winning again
yeah I think so yeah okay pretty
interesting game thanks for watching and
I'll make a new 15-minute video soon i
think its own it's a good format to
really a yeah do a little bit of a
deeper comentarii um compared to to the
blitz games alright thanks and talk to
you soon with the new game